un organisme particulier comptable
annonce cette semaine en début de
semaine qu'inévitablement la mise en
place sur trois ans de ce reste à charge
0 se traduirait par une hausse des
cotisations de l'assurance mutuelle de 6
à 9% et qu'elle atteindrait
particulièrement les revenus les plus
faibles alors monsieur le ministre fasse
face à cette enquête
je voudrais savoir quelle est la réponse
du gouvernement porte à la concertation
qui a été mise en place aux procédés qui
permettra de le réaliser et aux
résultats qu'il en aura sur les
cotisations
les assurés je vous remercie
c'est un métier important celui que de
courtier en assurances et parfaitement
respectable mais je ne peux pas
totalement exclure que en l'espèce les
producteurs de l'étude soit comment
dirais-je intéressés ou désintéressés à
la réussite de cette réforme de quoi
s'agit-il
monsieur le président d'une réforme qui
vise à ce que le non accès aux soins
dentaires aux soins auditifs et aux
lunettes soient corrigés nous savons
tous nous les rencontrons tous les jours
que nos concitoyens ont du mal compte
tenu de l'importance du reste à charge
qu'ils doivent assumer ont du mal à
aller s'équiper en prothèses auditives
quand ils en ont besoin ou à recourir
aux soins dentaires et nous savons que
en dépit des efforts jusqu'à présent
réalisé par l'assurance maladie et le
cas échéant par les systèmes
complémentaires le reste à charge
individuelle est aujourd'hui
considérable c'est ce à quoi nous avons
voulu nous attaquer nous l'avons fait en
engageant des discussions très
approfondies avec l'assurance maladie
d'une part et avec l'ensemble des
acteurs qu'ils soient industriels ou
mutuelles qui interviennent en la
matière et au terme de discussions danse
et productive
nous avons mis en place un dispositif
qui garantira qu'au 1er janvier 2021
puisqu'il va se mettre progressivement
en place au 1er janvier 2021 nos
concitoyens pourront avoir accès à un
panier de soins dentaires auditifs et
lunettes avec un reste à charge 2 0
il est désormais temps que sur le
terrain les professeurs les parents les
élèves voient un changement et qu'un
terme soit mis un laxisme qui l'a que
trop duré
demain vous le savez avec le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner nous
avons une réunion sur pour le comité
stratégique sur la sécurité des
établissements qui nous permettra non
seulement d'avoir un raisonnement sur ce
qui se passe dans la classe et là
évidemment toute une série de mesures
sur le fait de conforter l'autorité du
professeur seront confirmés est prise il
y aura aussi des mesures sur ce qui se
passe à l'échelle de l'établissement et
surtout comment nous faisons en aide aux
établissements quand ils ont des
problèmes de sécurité mais il ya aussi
tout le raisonnement sur ce qui se passe
autour de l'établissement avec la
ministre de la justice avec le ministre
de l'intérieur nous avons en effet
encore bien des chantiers à ouvrir en un
an et demi nous avons fait progresser ce
sujet pas seulement par le discours mais
pour beaucoup de choses qui n'ont pas
été faites pendant des années monsieur
le sénateur vous êtes un inspecteur
général de l'éducation nationale
vous savez de quoi nous parlons et donc
comme salles aujourd'hui de se faire
reprocher d'avoir avancé en un an et
demi quand en réalité les avancées qui
ont eu lieu n'avait jamais été fait
auparavant
violence à l'école
nous n'avons pas besoin d'un énième
comité stratégique notre école a besoin
de professeurs respecter notre école a
besoin d'autorité monsieur le ministre
incarner l'autorité pas seulement en
paroles mais en actes
[Musique]